so i was watching your web series on
bailey street and you are
building a house from ground up this
this is clearly your dream right like
this this project is this the dream
project more than anything else you've
ever done is this no this has been
something kicking and screaming my wife
dragged me to i lived in this house for
26 years a house who was on a show
called living with ed yeah i've been
there since 88 i loved it i used to joke
but i wasn't entirely joking that i
would be composted out back yeah you
know and then she kept saying from early
on when we were dating in the 90s she'd
go hey you need more closet space i
don't have any whoa whoa honey okay okay
i hear you you got to find another guy
you got to start dating because this is
not going to work i i'm i'm never going
to move from this house ever read my
lips i'm never moving yeah and so i said
that and i meant it 93 94 95 finally by
2010 she had worn me down we had three
very successful years with that show
living with ed and acting career was
doing good and green product
endorsements so we had the money to do
it she said we've got the money now
please would you consider if i could get
you more solar rooftop space and get
more exposure for your panels if i could
get you a bigger vegetable garden i can
get you more room for a rainwater tank
on the ground would you move then i said
okay if you can find
a b c d e f g for this price for f
um yeah then i'll move yeah and uh the
[ __ ] did it she found the place and i
had a you know that's your quote not
mine i know yeah it's going to be good
when we're moved into this house and
happy about it i'll feel very good about
it all because you can only do so much
with a retrofit i'm starting with an 88
when i bought that home it was a 1936
energy inefficient house there was no
insulation the walls whatsoever i blew
it in no insulation in the attic but
these big recycled denim you know bats
up there did all this stuff one thing
after another i made it as efficient as
you could let me tell you what you can
do with new construction we can blow
incredible insulation in the walls it's
modern foam insulation the walls are 12
inches thick it's passive solar design
so winter time the sun is hitting the
glass summertime and a little before a
little after no sun is hitting the glass
incredible lutron smart equipment for
the lighting control shades and lighting
fixtures uh incredible high sear rating
heating and air units variable flow four
different zones it's amazing what you
can do with modern construction and
we're doing it all polar low water use
faucets and fixtures everything that you
can do we're doing it